COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some middleware pros
with their Bigtable performance.
Will we upgrade to the latest
version of awesomeness?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: For a
company like TimeSliders,
time series data is the backbone
of their business model,
but lately, it's been
the bane of their users.
Their main product is a
performance instrumentation
library that developers can
add to their mobile apps
to get runtime data
from the field.
Sadly, this process of
building and displaying
performance tables in
the report web pages
quickly became a bottleneck and
a less-than-ideal experience
for the majority
of their clients.
Thankfully, we
didn't have to look
too far to find the problem--
timestamps.
Now see, every 100
milliseconds or so,
their library would
log the battery status,
creating an entry
into Bigtable, where
the row key
consisted of the word
"battery" plus a timestamp.
Now, while this seems like a
straightforward implementation,
it runs into a problem
with hot-spotting.
Now see, when a row
key for a time series
includes a timestamp,
then all of your writes
will target a single node.
It'll fill that node,
and then move on
to the next node in the cluster,
filling that node, and so on.
This pattern creates
scenarios where performance
suffers for your application.
Addressing this problem
means leveraging
the concept of field promotion.
Now, this trick involves moving
fields from the column data
into the row key to make
writes noncontiguous.
Now, for example,
TimeSliders ended up
promoting the user ID
value from a column
to an element of the row key.
This change solved their
hot-spotting issue because
of the fact that the
identifier for users
provided a more uniform
distribution of row keys,
splitting writes across
multiple nodes in their cluster,
reducing hot-spotting,
and improving performance.
Now, in case field promotion
doesn't work for you,
then check out the article
linked in the description
below, where we cover a
few other alternatives.
Likewise, don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more great
Cloud Performance Atlas
content, because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]